the government's announced that all
kovid travel measures including
passenger locator forms and testing will
be scrapped for all arrivals to the uk
from friday transport secretary grant
shapz confirmed the changes in the last
few minutes
finally we're able to get rid of all of
the travel restrictions so there is no
more testing there's no more
quarantining there's no more paperwork
and today we will be scrapping the
passenger locator form on this friday i
should say uh meaning that you can
travel just like in the good old days we
know now that the level of vaccination
is so high uh this country of course led
on vaccinations but actually around the
world as well now it's come up uh it
means that broadly speaking you know
it's safe for people to travel around of
course we ask people not to go out if
the guidance says if you've got covert
don't travel but apart from that it's
safe to travel now and i think it will
lead to a big renaissance people being
able to get back together with friends
and families abroad they may not have
seen for a very long time no paperwork
is going to make that a lot easier to do
and it happens this friday morning